han pasado más de 24 horas desde que el
helicóptero en El que viajaba el Quien
fuera el ministro del interior de
Ucrania Dennis monasterski se derribara
aquí en este jardín infantil de la
población de probar y muy cerca de la
capital de kiev esta es una área
Residencial y a estas horas del comienzo
de la tarde siguen llegando personas
familias enteras incluso con sus niños a
rendir homenaje a quienes fallecieron
ayer 14 personas entre ellos uno de los
niños que hacía parte en el colegio que
estaba en sus clases y también nueve de
las personas que viajaban con el
ministro según se conoce en el momento
seis niños están heridos de gravedad en
una de los hospitales de la ciudad al
igual que diez adultos y esto ha causado
una gran conmoción no solamente en esta
área sino en el todo el país vemos a
madres explicándole a sus hijos lo que
pasó mirando les traen osos de peluche
traen flores tratando de aliviar el
dolor de lo que tiene la población que
los últimos días ha vivido grandes
eventos que realmente los han marcado
recordemos que el sábado pasado un
edificio en la ciudad de nípro fue
impactado por un misil que dejó al menos
44 personas muertos entre ellos también
niños el presidente
dijo que sea cual sea la causa de la
caída de este helicóptero está
relacionada con la guerra el gobierno
está estudiando qué fue lo que pasó se
dice que uneli se pudo haberse enredado
con una edificación pudo haber un algún
error del piloto o incluso un Sabotaje
lo que sí sabíamos es que el ministro se
dirigía a uno de los frentes de la de
batalla él tenía su cargo la parte de la
defensa del país la policía la guardia
de las fronteras los servicios de
emergencia están Bajo su cargo y él
hacía parte de ese pequeño comité que
tiene a cargo las decisiones de la
defensa del país desde que comenzó la
guerra